[Music]
I'm looking for Sam where are you Sam
are you from Sam Boston Boston where
abouts well then oh I know Waltham where
my first job was in Waltham the yeah
near the Totten Pond Road you know that
is yeah yeah I worked there years ago
it's too good to waste so first real
human moment I've had with anybody I
know in like 15 years I know I think you
over it yeah it doesn't make us any
money get back to do what you do best
Totten Pond Road Andy that's where I
work for congressman Robert Dryden oh it
was driving home from that job that I
heard that Thurman Munson had died
settle down kids me driving home from
Totten Pond Road in a way where all
three of us are connected now but not
Andy cuz you were Eddie what did you say
did you just add more when we were
clearly done were you from Susanna I'm
from Alabama oh you kidding yeah that's
funny wait a song about that earlier
we're in Alabama you from Birmingham
I've got relatives in Birmingham do you
do you mind Andy I'm minor up you go
ahead fun this is my fault
now what's that I don't remember where
they went to schools my fault
you
[Music]